bien bonjour à tous
madame messieurs on va commencer le
Medef pour rejoindra peut-être perdu
dans les couloirs
mes chers collègues également merci de
votre présence nous poursuivons donc nos
travaux
après cette première table ronde qu'on
vient il sera fait au sur la
simplification des normes et des règles
applicables aux entreprises alors c'est
un sujet
constant depuis des années la délégation
d'entreprise s'y intéresse bien entendu
on l'examine en ce moment même un
rapport qu'elle consacre au même sujet
mais pour les collectivités locales donc
on essaiera d'ailleurs de faire un
travail commun
Stéphanie entre les deux délégations sur
ce thème de la simplification parce que
parfois c'est lié simplification des
collectivités locales et dans
l'organisation
ça a aussi des conséquences sur les
entreprises
les rapporteurs désignés pour mener
cette mission d'information son Gilbert
Luc de vinasse et Jean-Pierre Moga qui
est absent aujourd'hui Olivier Rickman
afin de dresser un premier bilan nous
avons le plaisir d'accueillir ce matin
madame Stéphanie Tondini élu de la CCI
Paris de France salut Monsieur Bruno
nandero président de la commission
juridique de la CPME
Madame Christine Lepage directrice
générale adjointe en charge de
l'économie du Medef et Monsieur Olivier
Schiller vice-président du métier donc
je vous salue tous les quatre je vous
remercie de répondre toujours
favorablement à nos sollicitations on a
besoin de votre expertise à chaque fois
et c'est avec plaisir qu'on vous
retrouve
l'exemple récent du guichet unique
pour les formalités des entreprises nous
a montré que la simplification était
parfois complexe à réaliser
la délégation des entreprises avait
dressé en 2017 un bilan en demi-temps du
choc de simplification de 2013 2014
ensuite cette volonté de simplifier
c'est notamment traduite par la
reconnaissance d'un droit à l'erreur
dans la loi du dissout 2018 pour un état
au service d'une société de confiance
dites loi et socle
par la suppression l'obligation des
entreprises de fournir un extrait
d'immatriculation Kbis dans 55
procédures administratives en
application de la loi pacte en 2019
ou encore par la simplification de
procédure avec la loi du 7 décembre 2020
d'accélération et de simplification de
l'action publique dites loi asap
mais inversement la loi climat est
résilience du 22 août 2021 comporte de
nouvelles obligations à la charge des
entreprises notamment pour favoriser la
prise en compte obligatoire des enjeux
environnementaux
la simplification n'est donc pas un
processus continu loin sans faut nous
aimerions savoir s'il représentants des
entreprises estiment que la politique de
simplification en direction des
entreprises se focalisent sur la
réindustrialisation et la facilitation
des procédures de création de sites
industriels et semble oublier le reste
l'état n'a-t-il pas décalé son angle
d'attaque de la complexité
administrative concernant les
entreprises en considérant que numériser
ces simplifié
l'administration développe-t-elle une
culture de l'accompagnement des
entreprises
enfin avez-vous eu connaissance de non
recours des entreprises aux aides
publiques en raison de leur complexité
comme certains boulangers l'ont
récemment dit
sous c'est la parole pour 7 minutes
d'intervention chacun lors d'un premier
tour de table avant d'entamer un
dialogue avec les sénateurs membres de
la délégation aux entreprises et je
demanderai à chacun d'être bref pour que
nous puissions tous nous exprimer
bref cette minute mais pour les pour mes
collègues ça sera moins
deux minutes
pour la question comme dans l'hémicycle
je rappelle que cette audition sera
diffusée en direct sur notre site
et disponible en vidéo à la demande je
salue la présence de Monsieur Gontran
sur la liste de PME et je vous remercie
tous et je sais de la parole pour
commencer à Madame Tondini vous voulez
bien
[Musique]
merci merci monsieur le Président
messieurs les sénateurs je ne sais pas
s'il y a des dames sénateurs
mesdames et messieurs tout d'abord je
vous remercie de nous donner la parole
j'interviens aujourd'hui en qualité
d'élus de la Chambre de commerce et la
raison pour laquelle j'ai été désignée
rapporteur c'est que je suis une
praticienne du droit et ce dont je
voudrais vous parler c'est de la
pratique des TPE PME je dirais vu au
plus près les mains dans le cambouis
quand on interroge un chef d'entreprise
sur la simplification des normes ça veut
dire quoi concrètement pour lui et quand
je parle des entreprises je parle des
TPE PME que je côtoie depuis un petit
peu plus de 20 ans qu'est-ce que ça veut
dire pour lui ça veut dire d'une part
facilité l'accès à l'administration
facilité l'accès aux institutions de
l'État
c'est-à-dire faciliter certes ces
démarches déclaratives évitez les
doublons inutiles on en reparlera c'est
aussi améliorer le processus de
communication avec les services de
l'État lui-même donc rassurer
celui qui à la fois un contribuable et
injusticable en plus d'un entrepreneur
parce qu'il y a des vrais enjeux
rappelons que c'est quand même le pot de
terre contre le pot de fer avec le
privilège du paiement préalable quand il
y a des procédures fiscales etc donc la
qualité des échanges avec
l'administration et l'État sont un sujet
extrêmement important pour le chef
d'entreprise on va en reparler avec le
guichet unique on va en reparler avec le
non accès aux grèves des tribunaux de
commerce pour les entrepreneurs et tous
ces mécanismes que l'on a de plus en
plus fréquemment aujourd'hui c'est à
dire des machines en face de nous et non
plus des hommes
voilà et améliorer aussi la rapidité du
processus de communication avec les
institutions de l'État pourquoi je
rappelle que l'entrepreneur contribue à
des justiciers par des délais très
strictes par des prescriptions qui sont
très fortement sanctionnés pour encore
une fois des TPE et des PME qui n'ont
pas forcément des budgets et des trésors
extrêmement importantes pour fonctionner
je voudrais parler également de la
simplification de l'accès au
juridictions on simplifie l'accès au
juridictions par un simple formulaire on
saisit des juridictions telles que le
tribunal de commerce c'est très bien les
Justiciers peuvent y aller tout seul
mais je vous pose la question
lorsqu'un justiciable saisie le tribunal
de commerce pour demander par exemple
une mesure d'accompagnement une mesure
destinée à sauver son entreprise il
demande par exemple une mesure de
sauvegarde mais il ne sait pas que quand
on demande une procédure de sauvegarde
il ne faut pas être en état de cessation
des paiements il arrive devant ses juges
que font les juges ils appliquent
purement et simplement donc s'il y a
étape cessation des paiements il
provoque au mieux un redressement
judiciaire au pire une liquidation
judiciaire donc il vient les mains dans
les poches en demandant un
accompagnement à une protection il
repart avec une équidation judiciaire
j'ai presque envie de dire situation
inverse qui est pire il vient en
demandant une liquidation judiciaire
pourquoi parce qu'il n'a plus trésorerie
ne peut pas payer ses salariés il a de
fortes dettes il est dans un état de
détresse énorme et les juges font une
application stricte de cet état de
cessation des paiements et il considère
qu'avec un vague échéancier par exemple
de l'URSSAF ou un vague échéancier d'un
créancier qui n'a que très peu de valeur
il n'est pas en état de Sécession des
paiements il repartie de bonus avec sa
détresse parce que derrière il ne peut
pas payer ses salariés il ne peut pas
continuer son exploitation et en lui a
refusé sa liquidation judiciaire voyez
un petit peu le côté automatique du
mécanisme qui peut être extrêmement
préjudiciable mais ce qui nous amène
immédiatement au second qui concerne la
simplification puisque c'est notre sujet
aujourd'hui le second point c'est la
complexité intrinsèque des normes
elles-mêmes
on vit dans un monde complexe et la
nature humaine est complexe je voudrais
rappeler une citation de notre poète
Jacques Prévert préféré le désordre des
êtres et dans l'ordre des choses le
désordre des êtres est dans l'ordre des
choses ça veut dire que la relation
humaine est complexe comment faire en
sorte que la norme destinée à créer un
ordre ne soit pas complexe
c'est forcément complexe de manière
intrinsèque et c'est ça la difficulté
simplifier certes mais la nature de la
norme rend la chose complexe par exemple
2016 on a une réforme sur le droit des
contrats quel était l'objectif de cette
réforme on a codifié la jurisprudence de
la Cour de cassation on voulait rendre
plus audible des dispositions du code de
1804 avec certains mois archaïques mais
ce qu'on avait oublié c'est que les
praticiens connaissaient parfaitement
ces dispositions ce code civil parce que
c'était très ancien et toutes les
carences tous les mots qui pouvaient ne
pas être immédiatement abordable la
doctrine et la jurisprudence les avaient
complétées donc nous les praticiens ont
maîtrisait parfaitement le droit des
obligations telles qu'il était qui est
quand même un pilier du droit des
affaires il faut pas l'oublier
or quand on lit les conventions
légalement formés tiennent mieux de loi
à ce qui les ont faites est-ce que le
justiciable lambda béotien du droit va
savoir ce que ça signifie et quand on
dit les conventions doivent être
exécutées de bonnes foi est-ce que pour
autant la justiciable va savoir ce qu'il
y a dans la complexité de cette
disposition non pourquoi parce qu'il y a
des combinaisons avec d'autres articles
qui sont faites on pourrait répondre à
des cas d'espèces la norme est complexe
la simplifiée comme ça n'est pas simple
alors je ne viens pas non plus qu'avec
des problèmes en vous disant attendez ne
simplifions pas c'est trop compliqué ne
touchons à rien non ce que je suis en
train de dire c'est que une
simplification du droit certes mais de
manière chirurgicale en suivant un
objectif déterminé qui doit être suivi à
chaque étape de la simplification ne
perdons jamais le cap que l'on s'est
fixé au début exemple pour les normes
relatives à l'emploi moi je suis très
attachée aux gens qui veulent travailler
qui ont envie de travailler qui se lève
le matin et qui on les voit dans toutes
les classes on les voit le matin cela
ils sont prioritaire quand on simplifie
les lois sur l'emploi priorité à
l'emploi et à ceux qui ont envie de
travailler une fois qu'on a ça on peut
simplifier le reste en matière de
procédure collective pourquoi ne pas
s'occuper de cet état de cette notion
d'état de cessation des paiements
puisqu'on a vu les juges ont un large
pouvoir d'appréciation avec des
difficultés mais c'est très ponctuelles
encore une fois c'est des points les uns
derrière les autres le pacte du trail
c'est un outil magnifique que specte du
trail qui permet la transmission du
patrimoine dans un cercle familial c'est
un actif immobilisé le transférer
nécessite énormément de disponibilités
pour payer la plus-value les droits
d'enregistrement et c'est pour ça que ça
n'est pas possible donc c'est un système
d'abattement qui est formidable pourquoi
ne pas aller jusqu'au bout pourquoi
limiter à 70 ans l'âge du donataire
pourquoi imposer une pleine propriété
pour l'abattement etc etc pourquoi ne
pas aller jusqu'au bout fixe le cap et
on avance
pour conclure je vous propose juste
trois petits exemples très concrets et
j'en terminerai par là je propose d'une
part l'accélération du programme dites
le nous en une fois lorsque le
contribuable dépose une déclaration sur
un site de l'État il ne faut pas qu'il
soit obligé de le refaire encore et
encore par exemple système
d'immatriculation on dépose sur la NTS
on le refait sur la taxe sur les
véhicules de société pourquoi c'est
dommage alors plus ambitieux et je sais
qu'il y a des obstacles la création d'un
coffre fort numérique alors on sait
qu'avec les cyberattaques actuellement
c'est un progrès extrêmement ambitieux
mais on est en pleine révolution
technologique c'est quelque chose qui
est possible un coffre-fort ou on
déposerait l'ensemble des documentations
du contribuable et l'administration
viendra les chercher en une fois en
outre sa présente de nombreux avantages
pour l'administration qui peut regarder
l'ensemble des documents et puis les
comparer
enfin j'ai pas parlé vraiment du guichet
unique juste deux mots
je suis avocate du droit des affaires
dans le civil dans le privé donc je fais
des formalités pour les sociétés tous
les jours mon assistante menace d'une
grève pourquoi depuis le 1er janvier je
ne passe plus aucune formalité je ne
peux plus régulariser je dois supprimer
le dossier repayer régulariser et j'ai
des rejets pour des demandes de pièces
qui ne me sont pas faites on a ouvert un
faux greffe je peux vous dire qu'on a
sauté dessus immédiatement on a sauté
dessus pour régulariser un certain
nombre de choses le lendemain la moitié
des fonctionnalités n'était plus là par
exemple la transformation n'était plus
possible
c'est dommage ça fonctionnait
parfaitement franchement Infogreffe
fonctionnait parfaitement le guichet
unique fonctionne pas donc là si vous
voulez aussi nous voulons immédiatement
simplifier la vie de milliers
d'entreprises remettez en fonctionnement
remettons en fonctionnement Infogreffe
pendant un mois le temps que le guichet
unique fonctionne correctement parce que
là on commence à avoir des drames au
niveau des entreprises les formalités
juridiques des sociétés sont un
véritable enjeu je vous remercie pour
votre attention
que vous avez peut-être eu au MEDEF ou à
CPME
Bruno Le Maire a demandé à l'INPI de
basculer une partie des procédures de
modifications les plus urgentes
au format papier
afin d'assurer aux professionnels et aux
particuliers la possibilité d'effectuer
leur démarche sur de bonnes conditions
dont la simplification c'est pas
toujours la numérisation
les usagers pour l'encadrer à leur
réseau consulaire chambre de commerce
chambre de métier agriculture le
formulaire papier correspondant à leur
démarche qu'on fait depuis à peu près
250 ans voilà alors Monsieur don d'euro
[Musique]
vous avez la parole
merci beaucoup monsieur le Président
donc j'interviens au nom de la CPME je
suis professeur des universités en droit
spécialisé en droit des affaires et je
suis avocat
la question de la simplification des
normes ça fait longtemps qu'on en parle
on a eu effectivement une vague de
mesure de simplification
avec des questions régulières des
pouvoirs publics sur précisément comment
simplifier parce qu'on se dit que le
milieu juridique de l'entreprise est
tellement compliqué que forcément on
doit pouvoir simplifier mais pour faire
c'est pas un jeu de mots mais c'est
quelque chose qu'on entend et qu'on
écrit et qu'on dit souvent c'est que
simplifier c'est compliqué parce que ça
a l'air comme ça très basique très
simple très élémentaire de se dire que
et bien il y a un système compliqué on
va enlever des choses remplacées par des
choses plus faciles à appliquer et
finalement et bien on aura simplifié le
droit mais déjà quand on parle de
simplifier on parle ici de simplifier
les normes rien que ça c'est déjà très
compliqué parce que norme vous
parlementaire pensez bien sûr à la loi
éventuellement aux ordonnances mais on a
les décrets on a des espèces de
nouvelles formes de Nord qui sont ce
qu'on appelle c'est pas très joli mais
les FAQ on voit apparaître sur les sites
des ministères des choses alors
qu'est-ce que c'est des formes de
réponse ministérielles mais des fois
c'est des normes qui naissent et qui
sont accessibles simplement par le site
du ministère l'engagement de
responsabilité des entreprises qui
interdisaient aux grandes entreprises de
distribuer des dividendes on s'imaginait
que ça allait être une loi non c'était
une réponse enfin une suite de réponse à
des questions mais voilà c'était quelque
chose il fallait être prévenu de ça il
fallait aller consulter le site de Bercy
pour y avoir accès et puis il y a un
maquis qui est le droit produit par ce
qu'on peut appeler le droit dérivé droit
produit par les autorités
administratives indépendantes par les
interprétations de l'administration on a
en fond le droit européen qui nous dicte
un certain nombre de choses et puis on a
par dessus ça si ce n'était pas assez
compliqué on a tout là qui
jurisprudentiel qui en permanence
enrichie précises et donne de nouvelles
solutions que les entreprises et leurs
conseils doivent connaître alors il faut
comprendre que l'entreprise est
particulièrement une tpeme elle a pas
pour métier et elle a même pas pour
capacité de connaître ces évolutions
permanentes de son milieu juridique elle
peut pas maîtriser si on prend rien que
le droit des contrats et les basiques du
droit des contrats qui évoquaient madame
Tondini
rien que ça ça serait déjà compliqué
mais on ajoute à ça le droit de la
consommation qui de toujours plus
complexe avec des sanctions on ajoute à
ça le droit social le droit fiscal le
droit entre guillemets réglementaire de
l'activité de l'entreprise et on peut
imaginer que entreprise doit prendre
quelqu'un à plein temps pour ou
plusieurs personnes ne serait-ce que
poursuivre cette évolution des normes il
manque sans doute de la pédagogie
c'est-à-dire que on peut prendre un
exemple très simple une révolution qui a
intervenue en 2022 qui est le nouveau
statut de l'entrepreneur individuel 4
millions et quelques deux personnes se
retrouvent
avec finalement assez peu d'informations
avec un bouleversement de leur
organisation patrimoniale j'étais
commerçant j'ai maintenant à partir
entre le 14 mai j'ai un seul patrimoine
le 16 mai j'ai deux patrimoines qui sont
apparus bon mais finalement il n'y a pas
une éducation de l'entrepreneur
véritable à ce type d'évolution la loi
pacte on a inventé son apport en termes
de simplification mais c'était quand
même un
pas un monstre ça serait trop de dire ça
mais c'était quand même un texte très
important très riche pour un professeur
et avocat c'était un investissement très
important de comprendre tout ce que
disait ce texte j'imagine que le chef
d'entreprise n'a pas forcément le loisir
de se dire aujourd'hui je ne travaille
pas parce que je vais essayer de
comprendre ce que la loi pacte change
pour moi bon
il y a pas effectivement le système est
assez souvent sans pitié c'est à dire
que
et bien finalement cette complexité
juridique elle est appliquée aux
entreprises sans véritable mesure
d'indulgence et on entend on voit pas de
chefs d'entreprise dire c'est trop
compliqué pour moi je fais n'importe
quoi et je l'assume on a effectivement
des renonciations à bénéficier de
dispositif parce que parfois des petites
choses ou parfois des choses
gigantesques les rendent inapplicables
ou découragent
sentir le temps et l'énergie qu'il
faudrait pour les maîtriser il y a une
tendance qu'il faut indiquer au
législateur je trouve c'est une prudence
qui devient une gêne pour le justiciable
c'est vous avez en tant que législateur
le vous n'est pas vous
nominatif mais il y a une tendance du
législateur en France quand il veut
simplifier ou quand il veut innover à ne
pas supprimer l'existence c'est-à-dire
que peut-être par crainte peut-être par
prudence peut-être en se disant que
quelqu'un quelque part trouve une
utilité à quelque chose qui existe on
fait du nouveau mais on ne supprime pas
les strates qui préexistent et du coup
on a des empilements de dispositions et
ce qui rend souvent le système plus
compliqué je prends à nouveau l'exemple
de l'entrepreneur individuel certes on
ne peut plus choisir le statut de IRL
mais les 97000 IRL qui s'était institué
continue à avoir ce régime donc on aura
cette
cette créature un peu exotique et de
moins en moins connue que qui est le IRL
et qui progressivement disparaîtra mais
les avocats ou les experts-comptables ou
tout conseil continueront à être
confronté à ce type de créatures
et puis et je terminerai là-dessus il y
a des grands chantiers alors dans la
note qu'on vous communiquera on a listé
un certain nombre de mesures techniques
de simplification qu'on peut envisager
mais une mesure parmi d'autres s'il
fallait la choisir simplifions les
formes sociales accessibles aux
entreprises c'est à dire que
quelqu'un qui commence une activité est
confronté alors une personne physique à
la rigueur aujourd'hui à un choix
possible qui est l'entrepreneur
individuel mais si quelqu'un lui
conseille ou si elle a envie d'être en
société elle va avoir plusieurs formes
qui ont l'air interchangeable mais qui
ne sont pas en réalité qui ont des
avantages qui ont des inconvénients qui
ont des complexités plus ou moins grande
et ses choix à faire au démarrage d'une
entreprise il pourrait être à la fois
réduit parce que avoir un choix entre
plein de formes juridiques je ne suis
pas sûr que ce soit une richesse
véritable de notre droit c'est plus
quelque chose qui vient gêner
l'entrepreneur qui commence et puis
encore une fois
accompagnons l'éducation l'information
des entrepreneurs pour qu'ils se
retrouvent plus facilement dans ce
contexte juridique qui est très très
très complexe
merci merci déjà aux deux intervenants
pour avoir bien cadré les 7 minutes donc
c'est parfait madame Lepage je vous
laisse la parole merci monsieur le
Président Monsieur les coraux le corps à
porteurs madame et messieurs les
sénateurs merci de nous donner
l'opportunité de nous exprimer sur un
sujet qui le compte évidemment on vient
de l'entendre avec Madame Tondini
monsieur danser énormément pour les
entreprises parce que c'est toi c'est un
enjeu de compétitivité et d'être
activité qui est très fort évidemment
pour nous et on estime en effet qui a
énormément de marge de manœuvre encore
qui de progrès en tout cas qui existe
aujourd'hui la France dans le domaine de
fardeau administrative
occupé un rang qui est assez peu
enviable puisqu'on est classé alors
évidemment il y a différents classements
mais 65e sur 140 très loin derrière le
Royaume-Uni qui est 21e l'Allemagne 15e
ou les États-Unis 14e donc effectivement
ce seul chiffre nous dit dans quel sens
il faut aller sur ce qui a été fait et
monsieur le Président vous les avez
cités les lois de ces dernières années
pacte ASAP euh l'État au service d'une
société de confiance et la loi de
simplification sur industrie verte sur
laquelle on a commencé à travailler
vont dans ce sens là pour autant ce qui
nous frappe c'est que le flux ne diminue
pas et si on doit encore chiffrer donner
des chiffres dans ce domaine-là le CD
nous dit que sur le coup de la
complexité administrative c'est 3 à 4%
du PIB c'est à dire 60 à 80 milliards
donc on parle le sujet vraiment
essentiel et cette réglementation
foisonnante complexe elle a un coût
important et une insécurité juridique
qui est très difficile à vivre comme
vous le savez pour les entreprises
quelques chiffres à date donc on a on ne
parlait depuis 2017 on a 320 000
articles législatifs et réglementaires
qui sont actuellement en vigueur 44 lois
ont été promulguées depuis 2017 27
projets de loi sont votés 70 ordonnances
1700 décrets réglementaires sont publiés
et le texte le nombre de textes
réglementaires c'est accru de 127% les
lois de 65% mais les textes
réglementaires de 127%. pour donner des
exemples concrets la loi agé comportée
très articles au départ elle a été
adoptée avec 130 articles et 95 décret
d'application donc 25% d'ailleurs n'ont
pas été adoptés ce qui rend les choses
compliquées pour une entreprise qui en a
une partie est en attente pour le reste
de même la loi climat est résilience 69
articles au départ 305 à l'arrivée et
environ 160 décrets d'application
donc tout ça marque vraiment une
augmentation très significative des
normes alors
ça c'était les points négatifs
maintenant je vais passer aussi à
d'autres points positifs et leur vendant
négatif c'est que c'est l'accompagnement
vous y avez fait référence et vous en
avez parlé monsieur dansero sur les nous
on trouve quand même que les FAQ qui ont
été mises en place nous aident
énormément on l'a vu sur les aides covid
on l'a vu sur le le d'autres sujets la
loi agé avec l'article 13 de la loi
aggèle par particulièrement ça aide les
entreprises ça leur donne comme une
explication et je dois reconnaître qu'on
a beaucoup travaillé avec
l'administration sur ces sujets là pour
quand c'était pas assez clair demandez à
éclaircir des points donc ça c'est un
aspect vraiment fondamental qui va dans
le très bon sens on demande que ça
persiste évidemment et que peut-être en
aille encore plus loin dans la rédaction
de fiches pratiques à chaque fois qu'il
y a des textes et donc ça c'est le point
positif en revanche le point à améliorer
alors on voit deux principaux que ce
soit d'abord en amont ou en en amont
c'est des études d'impact sérieuse et
abouties on ne les voit pas et on a vu
certains textes qui font que on demande
sur des textes mais particulièrement sur
climat et résilience qu'on nous demande
des économies de CO2 sur des points qui
finalement ne portaient pas leur fruits
on les a fait chiffrer derrière on a vu
que c'était pas du tout ça donc ces
études d'impact c'est pas aux
entreprises de les faire aux
représentants des entreprises de les
faire c'est vraiment à l'état de les
faire en amont et c'est vraiment
essentiel c'est pas la peine d'imposer
aux entreprises des règles qui
finalement ne portent pas leurs fruits
autant qu'on aurait pu le souhaiter
parce que c'est la norme c'est du
travail c'est du coup et si le résultat
n'est pas là ça devient beaucoup plus
grave encore et de la même façon en aval
on demande vraiment à ce qu'on puisse
évaluer ces normes les contrôler et les
simplifier si nécessaire donc ces deux
points qui sont vraiment un défi
important aussi bien en amont qu'en aval
qui sont relativement peu mis en place
aujourd'hui
ce sont nos demandes principales alors
sous quelle forme ce qu'il faut une
commission enfin ça je saurais pas le
dire mais en tout cas il est essentiel
de le faire et vraiment j'insiste sur la
partie amont climat est résilient ça a
été de ce point de vue là un exemple de
ce qu'il ne faudrait pas faire je vous
remercie beaucoup merci Madame Lepage
monsieur Schiller oui monsieur le
Président merci beaucoup pour pour votre
invitation puis cette initiative sur la
simplification administrative bonjour
mesdames et messieurs les sénateurs
alors cette simplification est très
importante pour pour les ETI pour pour
deux raisons d'abord parce que nous
produisons massivement en France nous
avons moins des centralisé que que les
grandes entreprises et puis aussi parce
que nous sommes pris en sandwich entre
les PME qui doivent faire face à moins
de normes et puis les grandes
entreprises qui ont des moyens beaucoup
plus importants que les nôtres pour pour
y répondre quelque chose que je connais
bien parce que en plus de mes fonctions
du métier je suis pas juriste je je suis
je dirige une entreprise une entreprise
c'est intermédiaire qui intervient dans
le domaine de la santé notamment des
produits pharmaceutiques dessinés au
dentistes nous avons 2000 salariés à
travers le monde avec des usines dans
différents pays ce qui peut être faire
des comparaisons très intéressantes
alors l'avenir n'est pas n'est pas rose
pour au niveau normatif comme comme la
signaler le représentant de la CPME
toute la réglementation extra-financière
qui qui va nous frapper va entraîner une
complicité extrêmement importante ce
sont des directives qui sont complexes à
interpréter dans leur contenu au niveau
des seuils et dans mon domaine
d'activité je vous donne juste un
exemple le médical device regulation qui
est le nouveau règlement sur les
dispositifs médicaux induit une
complicité considérable pour le
développement de nouveaux produits qui
fait que l'année dernière nous avons
lancé un nouveau dispositif médical aux
États-Unis au Canada et bien les
corn-notifiers qui peuvent nous donner
l'estampis ce pour pouvoir
commercialiser les autres produits sont
embolisés donc nous pensons avoir
l'autorisation au niveau européen en
2025 trois ans après les États-Unis le
Canada qui sont pourtant pas moins 10
ans en termes de protection des patients
alors ce contexte est connu est connu
des pouvoirs publics effectivement on a
parlé de toutes les lois pour simplifier
et une espèce de schizophrénie ou d'une
part on voit bien que les pouvoirs
publics essaient de simplifier les
choses pas dans le droit du travail avec
l'instauration des CSE ça c'était une
belle simplification mais parallèlement
nous avons dû faire face à l'index
d'égalité homme-femme maintenant l'index
seniorité qui s'annonce et puis aussi la
vie du monsieur le Président cette idée
brillante d'introduire le E dans la bdes
qui est devenu bdese alors évidemment on
est tous très impliqués sur l'égalité
homme-femme c'est absolument fondamental
et au-delà des hommes et des femmes sur
je dirais l'intégration de toutes les
populations en France quel que soit leur
origine évidemment que au niveau des ETI
on garde nos anciens le plus longtemps
possible d'être surveillante mentale
c'est pas une option mais en quoi est-ce
que ça avoir avec le dialogue en quoi
est-ce que ces bases de données qui sont
extrêmement lourdes à constituer
pourquoi remettre une couche
supplémentaire
alors pour objectiver cette situation on
a mené une enquête avec un cabinet de
conseils et nous en livrons les prémices
puisque l'enquête n'est pas encore
publique et qui correspond à ce que vous
aviez indiqué donc aujourd'hui il y a à
peu près 400 000 normes ça c'est le
stock auquel sont confrontés les ETI
donc il y a 400 millions qui
s'appliquent à nous en termes de stock
et en termes de flux c'est 700 nouvelles
normes qui arrivent chaque année
le coût est de 28 milliards d'euros pour
les ETI donc 2,6% du chiffre d'affaires
ce qui correspond à peu près au chiffre
qui avait été indiqué faut savoir que
quand il y a une nouvelle langue qui
arrive le coup pour la mettre en oeuvre
pour pour la comprendre pour l'intégrer
de l'entreprise et pour vérifier ensuite
que et bien ce que nous faisons
correspond à l'esprit de la norme ça
représente des investissements d'un peu
plus de 300 000 euros par an alors par
rapport à ça qu'est-ce que nous
proposons comme mesure alors au niveau
du stock déjà bien identifié les les
obligations qui sont redondantes parfois
on est obligé de fournir la même
information à l'administration plusieurs
fois donc pour réduire le stock ça c'est
la première étape au niveau du flux et
je suis tout à fait d'accord sur le
développement des types d'impact à
priori et puis un peu stériori ça c'est
absolument fondamental troisième élément
important c'est prendre en compte notre
taille 2 Ti qui n'est pas reconnu au
niveau européen qui fait que quand il y
a une nouvelle directive ou un nouveau
règlement il est normal de nous plus que
les PME mais moins que les que les
grandes entreprises
mais au-delà de au-delà de de ce constat
je voudrais comparer la situation en
France et au Canada on a une usine à
côté Toronto une usine à sa mort des
fossés qui à peu près la même taille et
on a fait un travail avec nos collègues
canadiens pour mettre en place une
politique de formation globale au niveau
du groupe pour adapter l'ensemble des
salariés aux nouvelles technologies pour
leur permettre d'avoir les outils
pouvoir progresser dans l'entreprise le
dialogue a été difficile parce qu'il
comprenait pas de quoi on parlait on
parlait de DIF on parlait de
compte professionnel d'activités on
parlait de CPA de toute une de tout un
environnement qui était complètement
compréhensible pour eux parce qu'il
disait mais enfin
pourquoi est-ce que l'État intervient
dans la façon dont l'entreprise doit
former ses salariés c'est le désert
social qui doit régir c'est ces
relations on a parlé aussi notre très
professionnel entretien professionnel
qui s'ajoutent aux entretiens annuels ou
regarde on fait le bilan sur l'exercice
passé et on regarde on donne des
objectifs pour pour l'avenir ça c'est
quelque chose qu'on fait une ou
plusieurs fois par an mais pourquoi
rajouter en plus un autre individu cet
entretien professionnel qui est de la
bureaucratie administrative mais qui
n'apporte absolument rien ni aux
salariés ni à l'entreprise donc il
faudrait vraiment pour réussir la
simplification administrative je pense
que si on refait des lois qui vont
compléter les lois qui ont qui existent
je suis pas sûr qu'on arrive aux
résultats je pense qu'il faut vraiment
ce qu'on appelle un paradigme shift ou
un choc culturel pour se dire bah voilà
l'état va s'occuper des fonctions qui
sont essentielles le code du travail
canadien compte 190 pages en fait 380
pages mais comme il est en deux langues
le Canada n'est pas moins 10 ans niveau
social les salariés sont parfaitement
bien protégés mais pour est-ce qu'on
laisse pas la majorité des
relations entre les salariés et puis une
entreprise pour être fait pas confiance
aux partenaires sociaux pour gérer ses
relations aujourd'hui en France une
association qui est plutôt favorable aux
salariés ni un taux de chômage qui est
qui est historiquement bas
il y a un désir des jeunes de meilleure
qualité de vie au travail si vous n'avez
pas une politique environnementale
dynamique vous n'arriverez pas à attirer
les talents donc pour attirer les
talents pour les garder vous êtes obligé
de mettre en place une politique
dynamique si vous formez pas vos
salariés vous allez pas pouvoir adapter
vos entreprises aux enjeux de demain
donc pourquoi pourquoi l'État doit-il
imposer dans le détail la façon dont les
entreprises doivent opérer pourquoi
est-ce qu'on peut pas confiance au
dialogue social et c'est ça c'est si on
n'a pas cette espèce de vraiment de choc
culturel où on dit on va passer d'un
paradigme à l'autre je pense qu'on va se
retrouver malheureusement année après
année pour discuter de simplification
administrative
merci d'avoir ouvert les questions on va
on va entendre les deux rapporteurs donc
Olivier Rickman peut-être pour commencer
oui merci monsieur le Président merci
mesdames messieurs pour votre
présentation c'est la première table
ronde qu'on fait sur ce rapport qui nous
a été confiés par la délégation et je la
trouve de par vos propos très très
intéressants parce qu'elle ouvre les
vannes et elle ouvre les choses je
voulais juste apporter une petite
précision à Madame tontini quand vous
avez parlé du pacte du treuil puis après
on en viendra au sujet des normes et des
règles parce que c'est important qu'on a
été avec Michel Canevet ici présent
fin d'année dernière corps rapporteur
justement d'une mission sur la
facilitation de la transmission
d'entreprise et inévitablement on était
sur le pacte du treuil et on s'est posé
la question à un moment de savoir si on
devait
et aller plus loin sur les dispositions
et sur les possibilités que donner le
pacte du treuil mais il vous a pas
échappé notamment avec un certain nombre
d'articles et d'interventions début 2022
que le pacte du treuil a été lui-même
attaqué et qu'un certain nombre de
personnes ayant un petit peu pignons sur
rue mettaient en cause la justification
du pacte du treuil dans la transmission
d'entreprise et la réflexion qu'on s'est
fait avec le président Babari et les
membres de la délégation mais les
corps-à-porteurs c'est de se dire on va
déjà commencer par protéger ce qu'on a
voilà et de sanctuariser aujourd'hui le
pacte du treuil les tenants et les
aboutissants du pacte du treuil avant
d'aller plus loin et de mettre encore
plus dans la fragilité un système qui
aujourd'hui est quelque part un peu
contesté voilà parce que les
explications que je peux vous donner
dans dans le domaine mais merci Madame
concernant la simplification des normes
et des règles
moi je crois en fin de compte monsieur
Schiller que vous avez posé dans un
premier temps la première question
pourquoi alors qu'on sait très bien
que la simplification des normes et les
règles aujourd'hui dans notre pays est
une question de compétitivité et d'être
activité pour nos entreprises et quand
on pose la question un chef d'entreprise
quand même un certain nombre autour de
nous la première chose qui lui vient à
l'esprit concernant le bon
fonctionnement de son entreprise c'est
quand même de dire on est assailli de
normes de règles qui nous rajoutent du
temps de travail vous avez parlé encore
de la certainement on va vers l'index au
niveau de l'emploi des seniors qui nous
rajoute du temps de travail qui nous
rajoute de l'emploi obligatoire parce
qu'on peut pas tout faire avec les
employés qu'on a ou de la prestation qui
coûte de l'argent à côté mais qui n'a
aucune production de richesse au bout
alors qu'on est des gens responsables on
sait très bien vers quoi on va aller ce
qu'on doit faire comment faire
fonctionner notre entreprise on a aussi
la université de se dire qu'on a des
comptes à rendre il y a pas de souci
là-dessus
les chefs d'entreprise sont pas
réfractaires à tout ce qui est normé
règles la preuve quand c'est très
intéressant pour l'entreprise si on veut
parler des certifications ou des
normalisations ils sont plutôt preneurs
puisque ça leur permet quand ils
arrivent à acquérir une certaine
certification on parle des iso on parle
etc d'ouvrir des marchés et d'accéder à
des marchés beaucoup plus intéressants
et beaucoup plus générateur de richesses
sauf que dans la plupart des normes et
vous en avez cité un certain nombre
elles sont très coûteuses et et supprime
la possibilité de créer davantage des
richesses moi j'avais deux questions à
vous poser au début de cette de cette
table ronde la première c'est d'où vous
d'où vous vient pour vous d'où vient
cette volonté régulière de complexifier
les choses alors qu'on a un discours qui
dit
il faut simplifier la vie des
entreprises pour qu'elles soient plus
attractive on ne volonté de
réindustrialisation de notre pays mais
en même temps en face on complexifie les
choses d'où ça vient
et en même temps si vous deviez citer
dans un premier temps 3
domaine ou trois indices forts de
suppression de normes et de règles sur
quel domaine vous iriez
merci
alors peut-être pas trois parce que
il va falloir qu'on aille plus vite
peut-être même pas deux mais illustrer
éventuellement mais en tout cas lorsque
vous répondrez au questionnaire
on sera vraiment preneur de quelques
exemples chacun de choses qu'il faut
mettre en très grande priorité quoi pour
la modification qui veut répondre à aux
questions de Olivier Rickman
[Musique]
je me lance je me lance d'où ça vient
tout à l'heure je vous ai indiqué un
désordre des êtres et dans l'ordre des
choses je pense que ça vient de là et je
pense que ça vient aussi du niveau
d'éducation des populations qui
augmentent de plus en plus et comme on a
de plus en plus accès à cette
information
et bien de l'autre côté il y a une
course en avant donc à une
complexification des normes à une
précision de plus en plus importante
d'énormes avant le Code civil c'était ça
et au fur et à mesure il enfile l'ange
parle du Code civil parce que c'est le
code de base mais pourquoi parce qu'on a
tendance à tout vouloir contrôler on a
tendance à tout vouloir mettre en place
et le législateur j'en ai l'impression
de ne se limite plus des objectifs de
l'article 34 de la Constitution mais va
beaucoup plus loin on en parlait tout à
l'heure avec l'entretien professionnel
ça peut être des battu mais c'est ça
pourquoi est-ce qu'on va aussi loin dans
le dans la règle ensuite vous disiez
quels sont les domaines de
simplification pour ma part un grand
domaine de simplification si on doit
remarqué à quelque chose c'est quand
même la fiscalité la fiscalité c'est
quelque chose qui est perçu comme
profondément injuste par les chefs
d'entreprise et quand on considère que
l'impôt est profondément injuste et ben
on fait tout pour l'éluder pour 6 ou
stress et on s'y met suit son mais pas
volontairement il y a plein de petites
taxes dont on a perdu l'origine on sait
pas d'où elles viennent on continue de
les payer avec un sentiment d'injustice
énorme et ça encore une fois je disais
tout à l'heure il faut s'en tenir aux
objectifs aux valeurs principales
l'injustice que ressent le chef
d'entreprise ça il faut s'y attaquer et
donc ces petites taxes là il faut les
fusionner avec d'autres et comprendre
pourquoi
merci d'autres interventions
non non la volonté de complexifier on
voit bien d'où elle vient si on a je
parle du droit des affaires d'abord on a
un droit qui veut tout encadrer
c'est-à-dire qu'on veut tout prévoir on
se dit que si pour que la loi soit bien
faite il faut envisager toutes les
hypothèses et puis forcément plus c'est
compliqué plus on essaye de rattraper ce
qui est à côté et au bout d'un moment on
a des textes qu'il faut sans arrêt
modifié qui évolue tout le temps il y a
aussi le fait qu'on crée des autorités
spécialisées qui chacune se dit si
j'existe il faut que j'ai enfin il faut
que je montre que on a bien fait de me
créer donc chaque autorité va développer
elle aussi son propre droit ses propres
règles et au bout d'un moment
effectivement tout le monde produit de
la norme et on a un contexte ceux qui
sont sous l'application de la norme et
bien ben ils vivent ils vivent dans une
espèce de de de de de de complexité
ambiante qui est gigantesque ça c'est
certain après effectivement s'il faut
chercher des enfin je crois qu'il faut
effectivement changer de paradigme pas
se contenter de dire à tel article on
pourrait enlever tel alinéa et puis on
vivra tous beaucoup mieux même si bien
évidemment il y a aussi de la
simplification qui peut se faire comme
ça mais il faut effectivement je crois
que c'est plutôt par branche entière du
droit qu'il faut raisonner c'est-à-dire
que le droit fiscal par exemple
mériterait un travail d'être passé en
revue pour être simplifié le droit
social le droit des sociétés voilà je
crois que on a devant nous une vie à
passer à tenter de simplifier parce que
ce travail qui a été fait pendant des
décennies et les chiffres qui ont été
cités sont impressionnants et quand on
parle de 400 000 normes il y en a
peut-être certaines qui sont bien plus
redoutables que d'autres on parle d'un
voilà c'est un travail de titan et bravo
à vous d'avoir le courage d'être prêt à
le mener j'ai envie de dire
malheureusement vous n'êtes pas les
premiers et voilà j'espère que on va au
moins faire en sorte que les choses
soient plus simples et mieux mieux
applicable après après que ce travail
ait été fait
merci je reprends c'est juste un clin
d'œil mais on dit les Français
cartésiens et je reprends votre
expression à propos des agences diverses
ça serait un peu je règlemente donc
j'existe faut remplacer le jeu je pense
donc je suis
allez madame Lepage
qui a été dit auparavant et d'ailleurs
il y en a une illustration très claire
c'est les transpositions de textes
européens ce n'est pas fait comme ça
dans les autres pays européens nous ont
transpose quasi systématiquement et
alors qu'il n'y a pas d'obligation de le
faire donc oui je d'ailleurs alors
pardon puisqu'on aime les chiffres ici
tous autour de la table en 2006 l'Union
européenne fixait une réduction de 25 de
baisse de 25% des coûts administratifs
entre les États membres la Belgique ABC
de 30%, l'Allemagne a aussi atteint son
objectif et pas la France donc
effectivement peut-être une application
alors sur les domaines sur lesquels on
pourrait simplifier mais moi je veux
effectivement je vois pas pour tous en
réalité faut pas se priver tout tout est
concerné le droit social vous la cité la
fiscalité et je dirais aujourd'hui
l'environnement parce que là on voit
beaucoup de textes et de normes
environnement mental c'est normal
d'arriver qui sont parfois
contradictoires d'ailleurs je pense
qu'on va en avoir l'exemple dans le dans
la loi environnement la loi Industri
verte et donc voilà un domaine un
domaine de prédilection mais de toute
façon ça concerne tous les domaines
alors moi ce que j'ai entendu sur c'est
la complexité technique à simplifier en
fait d'aller chercher dans les codes les
textes et de les supprimer il semblerait
que c'est relativement techniquement pas
facile à faire coûter prendre du temps
et autres et que c'est en général ce
qu'on nous oppose quand on dit mais
pourquoi alors cet empilement voilà
et on termine le premier tour de table
donc monsieur Schiller alors pour
répondre à votre première question
monsieur le Président si je vais résumer
l'origine de la quantification je pense
que c'est un manque de confiance un
manque de confiance envers les
entreprises donc comme je disais
monsieur monsieur moniro dansiro
du coup effectivement il faut absolument
madame Tondini il faut absolument tout
tout prévoir dans le détail si un cas
qui peut se produire une fois sur 10000
bah il faut quand même se couvrir au cas
où ça voilà et ça rend
les textes d'une complexité très grande
donc on parle beaucoup d'aller vers une
société de de confiance mais le
processus législatif est pas forcément
pas toujours cohérent avec cette cet
objectif
sinon sur le champ de la simplification
je suis d'accord avec ce qui a été dit
précédemment le chant il est très très
vaste dans le domaine social dans le
domaine
procédure de travaux dans le domaine de
lycée pe une espèce de contradiction
entre cette volonté de réindustrialiser
le pays effectivement on a besoin il
était territoires entiers où il y a plus
d'industrie il faut recréer des
industries il faut que les PME
grandissent pour devenir des ETI quel
mal le territoire mais si
les contraintes environnementales sont
sont trop importantes et encore une fois
bien sûr qu'il faut aller vers un
verdissement de l'économie bien sûr
qu'il faut aller vers la neutralité
carbone bien sûr qu'il faut préserver
l'eau et bien il faut le faire d'une
façon plus simple et là aussi si on fait
la comparaison entre la France et le
Canada on a l'impression qu'au Canada il
y a des pouvoirs publics qui sont là
pour soutenir des entreprises qui vont
pas qui ne vont pas
déroger
aux normes environnementales et mais qui
vont être là pour aider des surprise
alors que en France
bien souvent on est encore dans un
contexte de contrôleur contrôlé ou
l'administration et là plutôt pour
vérifier que surtout le fastien qui
puisse en quoi que ce soit déroger ou ne
pas respecter la norme donc là aussi on
va les changements de culture je crois
que aussi un vrai changement de culture
à mettre en œuvre de l'administration
pour l'administration soit là évidemment
pour préserver tous les citoyens
l'environnement mais aussi pour soutenir
les entreprises ce qui est pas encore
toujours le cas aujourd'hui
merci alors je vais passer la parole à
Gilbert Luc de vinasse pour une série de
questions
[Musique]
merci monsieur le Président je sais pas
si ça serait une série de questions mais
peut-être des réactions
d'abord
j'ai bien noté qui avait je vais prendre
un exemple pour les élus dans peu de
temps on va tous recevoir de la part de
banque demande de certains noms de
documents il va falloir envoyer en
dehors de la déclaration des impôts qui
changent tout le reste c'est de la même
chose qu'on peut trouver en ligne auprès
de la Haute Autorité de la transmission
de la vie publique bon donc et puis sur
la transposition de la réglementation
européenne et ça
sur j'ai un exemple dans mon département
sur les petits élevages de poules de
moins de 200 ou on a surtransposé et qui
pose qui va traduire la mort de ces
élevage alors qu'en Espagne c'est la
même réglementation et on n'a pas les
mêmes conséquences bon je sais pas si
introduit bien mon propos je voudrais
vous remercie de votre éclairage et si
j'ai bien compris madame Tondini
on s'attaque à quelque chose qui
voudrait simplifier quelque chose qui
permature crée de la complexité
en vous écoutant
effectivement il me semble puisque moi
je suis un peu le monsieur Jourdain de
du sujet il me semble qu'il y a besoin
de redéfinir les choses parce que ne
connaissant pas tout à fait ce qu'on
appelle norme réglementation si j'ai
bien compris la réglementation elle
relève de pouvoirs publics de la loi et
elle s'impose par contre les normes
c'est volontaire
donc il y a besoin me semble-t-il de
définir et il me semble que des
entreprises achètent des normes les
normes maintenant les normes ISO dans
leur intérêt et pour être plus
compétitif et me semble-t-il pour
acquérir un certain nombre de marchés
au-delà de notre territoire donc il me
semble qu'il y a besoin vous avez raison
vous avez essayé il y a besoin de
redéfinir de quoi on parle dans mon
esprit après
madame Lepage vous avez soulevé deux
points alors c'est vrai qu'elle chaque
fois il me semble quand on aborde les
textes de loi les uns et les autres on
demande qui est une étude d'impact je
sais pas pourquoi mais y compris dans
notre assemblée cette demande est
rejetée
et
depuis au Sénat et notre président
d'amarie le dit très bien on se lance de
plus en plus dans le contrôle après
votre donc ça rejoint les deux points et
le Sénat me semble-t-il sous la c'est
moi qui vais le dire sous l'impulsion de
son président Gérard Larcher on va aller
me semble-t-il plus dans ce sens-là
et le quatrième intervenant vous avez
fait des comparaisons avec d'autres pays
et ça ça me semble extrêmement
intéressant alors moi j'avais quatre
petites questions mais là il y en a une
vous avez commencé à faire des
propositions donc je vais pas la poser
mais
l'État et son en administration semble
ne semble pas utiliser ou propose
rarement le droit simple et les les
normes volontaires
alors est-ce que vous avez un avis
là-dessus j'ai cru comprendre qu'il y
avait une réponse parce que je me
demandais si c'était parce que tout
compte fait on n'avait pas confiance
dans nos entreprises
est-ce que vous ne regrettez pas la
disparition du conseil de la
simplification pour les entreprises et
est-ce que demain il faut pas s'orienter
comme l'Allemagne comme l'Angleterre
dépasser la simple consultation pour
aller vers une
une véritable coproduction entre les
différents acteurs qui
qui sont l'entreprise les investisseurs
et les pouvoirs publics
voilà mes questions que je me posais en
tant que Monsieur Jourdain
Monsieur Jourdain a quand même
approfondi le sujet qui veut répondre en
premier on fait dans le même ordre
alors pourquoi la norme est-elle
complexe en elle-même encore une fois je
pense que la norme est complexe parce
qu'elle va être précise tout simplement
et je pense aussi que depuis le 16e le
17e siècle on a tous accès à l'éducation
donc on est de plus en plus cultivé dans
le sens où on a de plus en plus de
notions et d'outils pour réfléchir et
donc on élève le niveau intellectuel au
fur et à mesure la capacité de
compréhension et donc plus ça va plus on
veut être précis on réfléchit aux
conséquences de la norme on veut
l'intégrer on met un mot à la place d'un
autre on vérifie la virgule tout ça
c'est le travail de législateur donc on
va très loin dans le travail d'analyse
le travail cérébral mais du coup on
complexifie on complexifie et après
quand nous on prend de la hauteur vous
savez on monte en balcon c'est ce qu'on
sait ce que fait votre commission en
fait un moment donné il y a une pièce de
théâtre elle monte au balcon et puis
elle regarde l'ensemble
elle se dit waouh finalement on a les
mains dans le cambouis mais c'est très
compliqué tout ça ben oui c'est
compliqué parce que vu d'ensemble ça
devient compliqué c'est pour ça que je
vous indiquais tout à l'heure que ce que
je préconisais c'était pas envoyé un
coup de masse dans l'ensemble mais au
contraire aller voir comment
perfectionner au fur et à mesure et
ensuite je reviens au côté culturel de
la chose on veut contrôler effectivement
on fait pas confiance aux entreprises
mais repartons des objectifs généraux
l'objectif général c'est quand même de
créer cette confiance avec tous les
entrepreneurs pas que les grosses
entreprises parce que c'est un petit peu
le sentiment qu'on peut avoir les hauts
placés de l'État avec les grosses
entreprises et puis tout toutes ces
petites TPE toutes ces petites PME
finalement elle se sentent pas trop
représentée donc il faut recréer de la
confiance avec ces personnes là est-ce
que vous faites en nous donnant la
parole et je vous en remercie encore
mais il faut créer de la confiance et il
faut que les chefs d'entreprise
comprennent pourquoi la norme est là
pourquoi l'entretien professionnel
a-t-il été créé à un manque de confiance
nous on fait déjà un dialogue social en
interne pourquoi est-ce que vous nous
proposer un entretien professionnel qui
derrière va générer des sanctions
prudomales très lourdes pour
l'entreprise si on ne fait pas
exactement le formulaire qui prescrit
c'est injuste pour l'entreprise
l'entreprise se dit c'est profondément
injuste moi j'ai deux salariés je
discute avec elle tous les jours au café
pour savoir ce qu'elles veulent faire je
suis bienveillante etc donc pourquoi
est-ce qu'on impose ça et en fait c'est
ça c'est complexe parce qu'on n'a pas
les mêmes personnes en face de nous on
traite pas celui qui a 500 salariés
comme celui qui en a deux et pourtant
l'obligation est la même donc plutôt que
d'essayer d'uniformiser un seul régime
pour tout le monde créons ce régime au
contraire de confiance montant au balcon
et on va essayer d'expliquer à chacun
pourquoi ça doit être fait et comment
après devant les juridictions ça doit
être appliqué on peut pas appliquer
cette norme pour reprendre l'entretien
professionnel on peut pas appliquer
cette norme de la même façon à celui qui
a deux salariés comme à celui qui en a
mis
[Musique]
alors quand on parle de norme
c'est pas de norme on fait pas de
distinguo la norme serait volontaire en
réalité une norme c'est toutes les
règles et c'est un terme qui est assez
commode pour englober aussi bien la loi
au sommet de la hiérarchie que la
réglementation technique qui aura été
émise par une autorité administrative
indépendante je fais la CNIL par exemple
donc c'est vrai qu'il y a tout un panel
de normes qui s'applique les entreprises
peuvent se doter de normes mais elles le
font parfois avec des codes de bonnes
conduite je pense au code à fait Medef
par exemple qui est un travail qui
permet aux entreprises d'aligner leur
comportement sur des normes sur
lesquelles elles se mettent d'accord et
c'est très vertueux aussi mais c'est
vrai que sa coexiste et ça fait enfin
les entreprises le font parce que elle
choisissent de le faire mais c'est vrai
que ça fait encore d'autres normes et
une entreprise entreprises peut
effectivement adhérer à un label et se
mettre dans les conditions de recevoir
ce label mais voilà c'est je dirais que
ces questions de label je sais qu'il y a
un débat sur le trop grand nombre de
labels mais c'est
dans mon propos quand on parle de
simplification c'est de tout ce qui est
obligatoire pour les entreprises voilà
c'est c'est ça et quand on parle de
co-production je vous entends
parfaitement et je crois qu'on sera tous
d'accord pour dire que c'est toujours
une bonne chose que ceux qui vont être
soumis à la norme puissent sinon
participer à son élaboration au moins se
faire entendre et c'est je crois ce que
nous faisons tous les uns et les autres
en permanence faire savoir que la norme
qui vue de loin a l'air très pertinente
quand elle sera appliquée aux
entreprises et bien les entreprises se
trouveront dans l'impossibilité de la
mettre en oeuvre ou avec un coût qui le
mode compétitivité est très important
avec un coût qui plombera leurs
compétitivité pour avoir satisfait
finalement qui avait l'air très
méritoire sur le papier mais en réalité
de l'époque je prends un micro exemple
mais il y a une loi de mars 2022 sur le
sport
cette loi impose aux sociétés anonymes
alors conseil d'administration de
lorsqu'il prend des décisions de prendre
en considération les enjeux sportifs et
culturels de la décision y compris pour
des entreprises qui n'ont aucun lien
dans leur activité avec le sport et la
culture pourquoi ça s'applique la tâche
des conseils d'administration qui
doivent toujours à mon avis je parle ici
en tant qu'avocat elle pouvoir démontrer
qu'ils ont pris en considération ça mais
parce que quelqu'un lors du processus
d'adoption de la voix il me semble que
c'était un amendement sénatorial mais je
peux me tromper quelqu'un a eu la bonne
idée de se dire ça serait bien que les
entreprises pensent aussi au sport et à
la culture alors bien sûr l'idée est
très bonne mais ça veut dire que les
conseils d'administration se retrouvent
avec une contrainte en plus ils sont
dans un contexte difficile de
compétitivité de coûts de l'énergie etc
et il faut que quand ils prennent une
décision ils puissent établir qu'ils ont
pensé aussi aux enjeux culturels et
sportifs une très bonne idée au départ
mais sa mise en œuvre vous voyez c'est
l'enfer pavé de bonnes intentions
merci Madame Lepage sur la défi merci
c'est le président sur la définition de
la norme j'ai pas prendre la parole
parce que dans mon deuxième juriste qui
viennent de l'expliquer en revanche sur
la confiance aux entreprises ça je pense
que c'est essentiel c'est vrai qu'on n'a
pas toujours le sentiment en France qui
est une confiance à l'égard des
entreprises et tous les exemples qui ont
été développés par Monsieur Sheller le
montre bien
et pourtant ça serait quand même utile
que
toutes ces économies qui pourraient être
faites si on simplifie les choses mais
aux soirées injectées dans l'économie et
sans qu'on parle de cadeaux aux
entreprises donc ça je pense
qu'effectivement il faut vraiment
changer cette façon de voir les choses
qu'on entend systématiquement dès qu'il
y a un texte qui peut en faveur des
entreprises c'est toujours un cadeau aux
entreprises de cadeaux entreprises c'est
avant tout un cadeau pour la France et
pour ces et pour ses citoyens
le sur la nécessité de co-construire et
l'élaboration des textes ensemble
absolument alors ça a été dit j'ai pas
reprendre mais un exemple dans la loi
Haget
on dit qu'il faut supprimer l'étiquette
caisse et les tickets de cartes bleues
très bien mais les consommateurs ils
sont absolument opposés donc peut-être
que si on avait échangé auparavant avec
eux on n'aurait pas voilà c'est pas
c'est un travail préliminaire qui semble
absolument nécessaire en effet ça se
fait de plus en plus je dois reconnaître
que quand même on a le sentiment que il
y a une construction il y a une écoute
peut-être plus développée qu'avant enfin
moi j'ai ce sentiment mais il y a encore
du chemin à faire dans ce sens là
[Musique]
vous avez parlé des relations entre
l'État et puis et puis et puis
l'administration je pense que là aussi
on est au cœur du problème j'avais été
nommé ambassadeur aux ETI en 2020 et
donc avec Macron ambassadrice
Jeanne-Marie Prost qui m'amuserait à la
Cour des comptes et puis la mise de
l'industrie on a fait le tour de France
pour
remonter les problèmes auxquels les
entreprises étaient confrontées et puis
aussi comme quoi est-ce que comment
l'étape pouvait et des entreprises on a
vu un exemple sur les tomates bio
producteur de tomates de tomates qui
avaient mis plus d'un an pour avoir la
certification bio parce que la fnor
était un petit peu n'avait pas les
ressources nécessaires pour pouvoir
répondre rapidement à une nous avait dit
il y avait un ami qui était
agriculteur en Espagne en Espagne il
avait eu son label en moins d'un mois et
avec une interprétation des règles
européennes beaucoup plus light que ce
que fait l'administration française donc
là aussi on voit on a une administration
qui là pour protéger le consommateur ce
qui est bien mais du coup moi je suis
sportif vis-à-vis des entreprises on a
parlé du pacte du trail il y a eu des
avancées qui ont été très intéressantes
notamment dans le cadre de la loi pacte
là aussi ça a été assez complexe que
l'administration retrace dans les textes
administratifs les lois qui avaient été
qui avaient été voté donc on a parfois
l'administration qui vit un peu sa
propre vie et qui
te tient pas toujours compte des
volontés du gouvernement et puis des
lois qui ont été qui ont été votées il y
a un autre exemple aussi loin
un petit peu de la simplification mais
sur les marchés publics en Allemagne
quand vous avez des marchés publics les
donneurs d'ordre veulent favoriser le
Made in Germany et bien de la méditation
en France si ça coûte 5 centimes de mois
en faisant venir des produits de de
Chine et bien si le produit chinois qui
va être donc là aussi on voit qu'il y a
une administration
régionale nationale en Allemagne qui l'a
vraiment pour soutenir l'entreprise qui
veut contribuer à l'industrie et c'est
quelque chose qu'on n'a pas en France
donc il y a sûrement aussi un changement
parlé de changement de culturel tout à
l'heure aussi à changement de culture
vis-à-vis de l'administration façon ce
que l'administration évidemment protège
tout ce qui doit protéger mais dans un
esprit également favorable aux
entreprises
merci est-ce qu'il y a d'autres
questions monsieur rapporteur
oui je voulais juste rajouter un petit
point et loin de moi l'idée de défausser
le Parlement allé parlementaires mais je
vous rejoins parfaitement monsieur
schillard et c'était un petit peu une
réponse je sais plus quel intervenant
quand vous dites le législateur a déjà
aussi lui l'habitude de complexifier les
choses
moi je dirais qu'on a toujours la
volonté de simplifier les choses après
comme vous l'avez dit Monsieur Schiller
il y a l'administration
et l'administration à sa façon de faire
et je comprends que l'administration est
aujourd'hui aussi très complexe
et elle vit dans un monde de complexité
et de suspicion et j'ai comment je
commence à me dire que finalement c'est
ce raisonnement de l'administration et
cette complexité de l'administration qui
rejaillit sur les décisions qui sont
prises derrière parce que dites-vous que
nous-mêmes de notre côté entre ce qu'on
veut les objectifs convoquent les lignes
on retrouve la même chose au niveau des
surtranspositions les directives
européennes ce qui ressort à la fin
c'est souvent beaucoup plus compliqué et
et beaucoup plus complexe que ce qu'on
aurait voulu nous à la fin parce que
l'objectif n'a jamais de compliqué les
choses
merci j'ai terminé par une question
peut-être de nos collègues Martine
Berthet
oui merci monsieur le Président moi
j'aimerais vous parler de RSE et de la
transposition de la future transposition
de la directive européenne nous avons
produit un rapport il y a peu de temps
dans lequel nous préconisons entre
autres une adaptation de cette
transposition en fonction de la taille
des entreprises des secteurs
d'activités nous avons supprimé
l'article au Sénat dans le projet de loi
qui devait autoriser le gouvernement a
transposé par ordonnance de façon à ce
que nous puissions au niveau du
Parlement avoir la main bon cet article
a été réintroduit à l'Assemblée
nationale ce que je voulais savoir c'est
avez-vous des contacts avec
les ministères pour la transposition de
cette directive européenne êtes-vous
associé au texte qui est préparé je vous
remercie
[Musique]
pour ma part j'ignore pour CCI je sais
pas
oui pour la CPME on est associé
alors oui on est très associé et si
j'avais su où on allait aborder ce sujet
j'aurais emmené le document qui va
s'imposer en termes de déclaration
extra-financière pour montrer à quel
point ça illustre tout ce dont on vient
de parler c'est à dire que pour des
entreprises et pas que les très grandes
c'est des déclarations qui font en
moyenne on a calculé que pour dire une
ETI peut-être monsieur Gervais il va
falloir deux ou trois personnes
dédiées à ça pour faire ces déclarations
c'est abyssal et on est encore qu'à la
déclaration générale enfin au texte
général et là vous savez que le hop
travaille sur les textes
sectoriels donc il va falloir faire les
déclarations générales plus qui va
s'adapter à votre
fait parlé par les différents secteurs
donc c'est énorme
on y a été associé oui d'abord on s'est
associé bien sûr on a fait le travail
nécessaire auprès de l'Europe pour
autant voilà ça reste comme ça on a un
peu simplifié des choses mais pas tout
et aujourd'hui on y est totalement
associé on travaille beaucoup avec les
Prague et les fragues travaillent
elles-mêmes avec l'issb le normalisateur
américain qui est vraiment essentiel
pour qu'on n'est pas en plus pour les
entreprises multinationales des
déclarations qui soient différentes à
faire en Europe et aux États-Unis donc
il y a on essaie de converger on essaye
je sais pas ce qui va se passer à la fin
ça a l'air d'être plutôt pas mal parti
mais il y a de telles différences
culturelles entre les deux continents
qu'il faut quand même pas espérer que ce
soit parfaitement similaire et donc
voilà en termes de contraintes
administrative là on a un exemple
vraiment essentiel va vraiment
importante de ce que ça va être et en
termes de coût et de difficultés et
pardon mais je voudrais juste rappeler
une chose c'est pas du tout pour un
criminer l'administration qui fait son
travail mais c'est vrai que parfois on a
une
réalise pas les réalités de terrain je
me souviens de cette conversation pardon
c'est un peu anecdotique mais je trouve
que ça peine avec
une personne en charge un chef de bureau
en charge d'un texte c'était de
nombreuses années et qui me dit mais ça
c'est compliqué je dis mais non c'est
pas si facile vous sortez ça c'est pas
compliqué c'est un directeur financier
qui va pouvoir
est-ce que tu as conscience de qui est
un directeur financier dans une PME et
peut-être même dans une ti enfin on
n'est pas en train de parler du
directeur financier d'une multinationale
qui a une équipe de peut-être plusieurs
dizaines de personnes avec eux un
directeur financier quand on va la masse
de travail qu'il a les textes là au
Journal officiel tous les jours et donc
je pense que de temps en temps il y a ce
manque de réalisme de du travail du
terrain parce que c'est vrai dans les
administrations il y a beaucoup de gens
qui peuvent travailler qui sont des
spécialistes des sujets donc qui en plus
rentre dans le sujet rapidement et que
ça cette différence elle est pas
toujours vue de façon évidente par
l'administration
au niveau du métier nous travaillons à
deux niveaux nous travaillons au niveau
européen pour faire reconnaître notre
catégorie au niveau européen alors on a
commencé à y aller tout seul Français
bon on a vu que on avait du mal à
convaincre nos interlocuteurs donc
maintenant on a une approche plus
globale ou on va voir les autorités
commission européennes avec nos amis
allemands et italiens etc pour
représenter pas seulement la France mais
maximum de TI européenne et voilà notre
volonté vraiment notre souhait c'est que
une proportionnalité dans les
contraintes qui pèsent sur les
entreprises aussi une province finalité
sur la limitation des aides puisque
aujourd'hui 251 salariés vous êtes
considéré comme grande entreprise voilà
donc ça pour nous c'est un combat
important c'est la création de cette
catégorie ETI au niveau européen et puis
deuxièmement évidemment dans la
transposition française de la directive
la c'est probabilité absolument
indispensable et que pour une société
comme septodon comme la mienne on
n'existe pas la même chose que Sanofi
parce que parce qu'on n'a pas les mêmes
moyens pour mettre en oeuvre tous ces
directives anticorruption de voir de
vigilance
tout ce qu'on nous demande de faire en
plus de notre métier de base
oui alors une ultime question Michel
canevêque merci monsieur le Président
merci à nos intervenants pour leur
question pour leur
interventions deux questions si vous
voulez bien d'une part la loi pacte de
2019 avait notablement simplifié la
question des seuils dans les entreprises
est-ce que vous pensez qu'elle est allée
assez loin où il faudrait-il aller
encore un tout petit peu plus loin
avez-vous des exemples par des exemples
de seuil que l'on pourrait améliorer
encore dans le dispositif qui qui existe
c'est une première question et puis une
seconde question qui a très aux
questions financières
dans les entreprises
on a l'image d'une administration
fiscale particulièrement tâtionne
véhémente dans notre dans notre pays
la loi dans la confiance a normalement
institué le droit à l'erreur et je
dirais normalement faciliter les
relations avec l'administration fiscale
est-ce que c'est une réalité aujourd'hui
est-ce qu'il y a encore l'appréhension
de l'administration fiscale dans les
entreprises ou bien est-ce que les
relations se sont dédmas améliorées et
peut-on encore les améliorer
alors je vais d'abord répondre à la
deuxième question qui me tient
particulièrement à coeur la première
aussi mais la deuxième me tient
particulièrement à coeur parce
qu'effectivement le contrôle fiscal est
toujours vécu comme un tsunami pour le
chef d'entreprise qu'il est quelque
chose à se reprocher ou pas on sait
qu'on a plusieurs personnalités de chefs
d'entreprise il y a celui qui est
extrêmement prudent qui fait attention à
tous étiquettes voilà et puis on a celui
qui se dit oh allez papy papy je vais
aller au restaurant avec ma famille donc
on a ces plusieurs typologies d'accord
mais c'est toujours vécu quoi qu'il
arrive comme quelque chose d'extrêmement
traumatisant pourquoi ces traumatisant
parce que c'est ce que je disais tout à
l'heure l'administration fiscale
bénéficie de prérogative extrêmement
importante notamment lorsqu'on vous
notifie un redressement fiscal pour
contester il faut d'abord payer
sur mes 8 premières années d'exercices
professionnels j'étais associé avec un
avocat fiscaliste donc il faisait du
contrôle fiscal et donc j'ai été formé à
ça donc j'ai vu les inspecteurs des
impôts comment ils fonctionnait comment
fonctionner les supérieurs hiérarchiques
etc encore une fois on a affaire à des
êtres humains qui viennent contrôler et
qui peut-être au fur et à mesure de leur
pratique estime que tous les chefs
d'entreprise à un moment donné ou un
autre de toute façon vont frauder donc
ils viennent alors encore une fois je
suis en train de faire une généralité
qui ne s'applique pas à tous
puisqu'effectivement il y a des
exceptions mais voilà quand on vient
contrôler une entreprise on vient
chercher la petite bête et tant qu'on
n'a pas trouvé on va chercher on va
chercher et quand on interroge les chefs
d'entreprise c'est le sentiment qu'ils
ont quoi qu'il arrive avec plus ou moins
de convivialité de cordialité peu
importe on va chercher la petite bête on
va appuyer sur ce qui fait mal et puis
voilà donc non c'est toujours mal vécu
parce que assez prérogatives parce que
c'est un peu puissant en fait
et on a l'impression de venir taper sur
les doigts du chef d'entreprise comme le
maître d'école qui le fait avec l'élève
qui a pas fait ses devoirs ou qui est
pas trop sûr d'avoir fait ses devoirs
voilà donc je sais pas comment modifier
cette relation là mais elle continue
encore aujourd'hui dans les TPE et les
PME première question sur la
simplification des seuils moi je trouve
ça très bien de jouer sur les seuils
parce que comme je l'ai dit tout à
l'heure une même norme ne s'applique pas
de la même façon à une grosse une petite
une moyenne une TPE un seul etc donc
alors je peux pas vous répondre
précisément sur les effets de ces seuil
parce qu'il faudrait que je travaille la
question et puis que j'aille interroger
mais d'une manière générale moi je suis
très favorable à ses seuil et à cette
intervention chirurgicale en fonction du
public auquel on s'adresse
oui je vais prendre aussi le même ordre
de réponse sur la sur la question de du
rapport à l'administration fiscale je
crois que même enfin je ne connais pas
beaucoup de chefs d'entreprise qui se
disent chouette un contrôle fiscal ça va
être l'occasion de mieux connaître
l'administration fiscale c'est
formidable mais plus sérieusement je
crois qu'il y a au-delà de la complexité
du droit fiscal assez de champs qui
peuvent donner lieu à interprétation
pour que on puisse toujours se poser des
questions et contester tel choix fiscal
qui aura été fait par l'entreprise donc
je ne crois pas que l'ambiance est
particulièrement changé mais
effectivement il faudrait un ressenti de
terrain que personnellement je n'ai pas
je n'ai pas aujourd'hui
sur la question des seuils elle est
vraiment très importante parce
qu'effectivement en quelque soit la
norme si vous êtes en dessous des seuils
où elle s'applique peu importe qu'elle
soit très complexe c'est entre
guillemets tant pis pour les autres mais
plus plus plus plus concrètement
les seuils ça peut être une vraie grande
difficulté de chaque norme ayant assez
facilement son propre système de seuil
de comprendre si on est dans le champ
d'application de la norme mais quand
vous avez un calcul qui se fait
effectivement en nombre de salariés et
de chiffre d'affaires ou totale du bilan
mais qu'il faut compter le nombre
d'exercices où on a dépassé et que
souvent on n'a pas prévu ce qui se passe
quand on repasse en dessous alors si on
a rien dit est-ce qu'on reste à de vitam
dans le dispositif enfin la loi pacte a
effectivement fait un travail de
simplification mais je pense que on peut
progresser en termes de simplification
des seuils après il faudra se demander
aussi et la question est très complexe
est-ce que finalement on veut un système
où tout le monde va tenter de rester
absolument en dessous du seuil parce que
une fois qu'on dépasse d'un salarié le
seuil là c'est tout le tout tout l'étage
supplémentaire de normes qui tombent sur
l'entreprise voilà c'est où est-ce qu'on
préfère doser en fonction de chaque
dispositif ce qui est un peu la tendance
quand même pour faire en sorte que
certains dispositifs n'est pas le même
critères d'application qu'un autre
dispositif parce que finalement dire que
les PME échappatus les ETI à la moitié
les grandes entreprises et elle s'est
plein pot c'est trop simple et on
comprend bien que c'est pas on va faire
une loi qui sera brouillonne si on fait
ça voilà
pour rester dans le même ordre pour
rester dans le même ordre donc oui bien
sûr que c'est un traumatisme je confirme
ce qui a été dit ou c'est l'inverse
aurait étonnant quand même parce que
c'est pas anodin parce que effectivement
les textes sont difficiles donc on sait
toujours pour une entreprise elle va
faire texte complexe parfois interpréter
donc discuter justifier cette
interprétation et puis parce que ça peut
avoir un impact extrêmement fort sur la
pérennité d'une entreprise et là je
pense que c'est ça que l'administration
fiscale doit absolument avoir en tête
c'est l'impact que ça sur la pérennité
de cette entreprise et éviter quand même
faire appliquer les règles soit mais
éviter des difficultés considérables qui
qui remettraient ça en cause cela dit il
y a quand même un gros travail qui fait
que l'administration fiscale et qu'il
faut c'est le c'est la relation de
confiance qui est mise en place
aujourd'hui par la DGFiP qui est en
train de se mettre en place et qui est
une une grande avancée qui est vraiment
essentielle et très et très apprécié des
entreprises c'est ni voilà et on y
travaille effectivement beaucoup avec
l'administration fiscale qui je dois
dire est très à l'écoute des entreprises
sur ce point là je j'attire l'attention
sur quelque chose et qui est toujours
une grosse différence entre c'est
peut-être une question de temps mais pas
seulement entre ce qui se discute au
niveau national avec l'administration en
l'occurrence la DGFiP et ce qui se passe
après sur le terrain et on le voit dans
tous les domaines il se perd beaucoup de
choses et une perdition très importante
donc effectivement le ressenti que nous
en tant qu'organisation bien on peut
avoir il n'est pas forcément le même sur
le terrain mais on espère que c'est une
question de temps de culture et de qui
va se mettre en place sur les les effets
de bord et les seuils alors pareil je
crois qu'il faut vraiment saluer ce qui
est apporté par la la loi pacte ça a été
une amélioration considérable parce que
ça permet aux entreprises d'anticiper de
pas passer d'un coup se retrouver sur
des textes qui les concernait pas un
mois avant et donc le délai qui a été
mise donc enfin en général je pense
qu'il faudrait le faire j'ai pas
d'exemple comme ça spontanément mais
dans le questionnaires on pourra on
pourra vous en donner et le monde plus
précisément mais c'est cette devrait
être mis en place pour pour certainement
tous ces sujets sur les seuils et dire
que les seuils ça peut être évidemment
un point négatif mais aussi positif pour
les entreprises je fais référence aux
aides on a les mêmes seuils pour les
aides les aides il a eu les aides covid
les aides d'énergie donc on voit bien
que dans l'autre sens les entreprises
sont sensibles assez seuil parce que
parfois elles échappent à des à des
contraintes mais parfois elles échappent
aussi à des êtres qu'elles
souhaiteraient qu'elle mériterait
d'obtenir
alors toujours dans le dans le même
ordre
au niveau de des relations avec
l'administration fiscale il y a du bien
et du moins bien donc j'ai commencé par
le bien le effectivement cette relation
de confiance ce partenariat fiscal qui
est qui est efficace et qui permet de
poser une question à l'administration
voilà
notre interprétation de telle situation
voilà tel traitement fiscal qu'on
propose et l'administration dit oui on
est d'accord on n'est pas d'accord et du
coup après il y a plus de risques en 4-3
fiscales on a on a fait la promotion du
dispositif dans le cadre de la stratégie
nation ETI à travers des clubs beauty
régionaux pour porter la connaissance
des déchets d'entreprise ou de leur dire
financiers ce dispositif qui est très
positif alors il y a du moins bien aussi
j'ai quelques exemples dans un moteur
des prix de transfert ou jouer des chefs
d'entreprise qui ont respecté les règles
de l'OCDE pour déterminer quel prise
elle est vendent à leur filiales ça a
été remis en cause par un contrôleur les
montants en jeu sont souvent parce que
la base une entreprise qui est fortement
exportatrice qui produit en France qui
forcément exploitatrice va générer des
flux très importants avec des filiales
et à partir du moment où on s'est remis
en cause les redressements sont sont
colossaux ça peut être des dizaines de
millions d'euros une entreprise comme ça
qui a dû négocier avec l'administration
en payant 500000 euros qu'elle devait
pas être payé mais parce que elle
voulait pas partir sur 10 ans de
contentieux d'autant plus qu'il faut
bloquer des sommes quand les entreprises
vont contentieux sur ces questions dans
la très grande majorité des cas elle
gagne mais il faut qu'elle ait les reins
et solide pour payer les avocats pour
bloquer des sommes sur des durées très
longues donc là il y a vraiment un point
noir sinon au niveau des seuils ou
effectivement c'est une amélioration et
tout à fait d'accord que ce serait bien
qu'on ait les mails seuils quel que soit
les lois il y a pas de raison qu'on
passe dans un cas à 250 salariés 300
salariés ça complexifie sa complexifie
il y a un point particulier que je
voudrais souligner c'était la question
du forfait social on parle beaucoup
aujourd'hui de partage de la valeur
entre les salariés
multiplie les entreprises
les PME ne payaient pas de forfait
social alors que les ETI et les grands
groupes payent 20% de forfait social sur
l'intéressement à l'intéressement dans
tout ce qui est extra légal tout ce qui
vient en plus de ce qui impose la Loire
et oui ce serait ce serait sur ce cas
précis bien que les ETI soient traités
comme les comme les PME et qu'on
favorise effectivement la mise en le
développement de ces accords de
partenariats
participation et puis et puis
d'intéressement
merci on va devoir
parler tout à l'heure donc du
traumatisme de l'administration fiscale
mais pour en revenir au sujet qui nous
occupent aujourd'hui à savoir la
simplification des normes je pense que
le traumatisme est des entreprises vient
du fait justement que
le juridique d'une manière générale le
droit est extrêmement complexe j'ai un
exemple qui me vient à l'esprit vous
allez immédiatement comprendre j'ai un
contribuable qui s'est fait redresser
sur plus de 90 000 euros il avait une
petite boîte donc c'était énormément de
trésor pour lui pourquoi parce que dans
ces assemblées générales ordinaires
annuel d'approbation des comptes il
n'approuvait pas sa rémunération donc en
fait ils étaient deux tout le monde
était d'accord mais il y avait pas cette
résolution d'approbation annuelle de la
rémunération on a un contrôleur qui est
arrivé qui a dit ah pas de résolution
donc la rémunération je la rejette donc
je crée un contrôle fiscal là-dessus et
je redresse et je considère que ce sont
des revenus de capitaux mobilier donc je
vous taxe sur les capitaux de mobilier
et en plus je vous redresse là dessus et
comme en plus je considère que vous
devez le savoir nul n'est censé ignorer
la loi je vous mets 80% de mauvaise foi
conclusion 80 000 euros il devait avoir
allez 15000 euros à trésorerie pour
contester je dois payer je demande le
sursis de paiement sur site paiement
rejeté parce qu'il n'avait pas des
garanties suffisantes parce qu'il
n'était pas suffisamment solvable à
titre personnel
liquidation judiciaire
et voyez pourquoi c'est traumatisant moi
encore une fois je parle des petits qui
n'ont pas le l'avocat fiscaliste qui les
a conseillés qui n'a pas l'avocat droit
des affaires je pense que vous avez
compris mon propos j'arrête pas
[Musique]
merci ça nous fait mesurer
l'amplitude de la tâche comme me le
disent chacun des cours à porteurs mais
vous serez trois il y en a un qui est
pas là
puis on va vous aider
j'ai une petite demande à vous faire
nous visitons notre délégation visite
Limpy le 8 février c'est donc très
bientôt on a souhaité aller voir comment
tout ça a fonctionné puisque la ministre
nous avait dit que ça c'était tout était
réglé on l'a dit on va aller voir on va
aller voir la source donc on va voir
l'INPI le 8 février si d'ici jeudi
prochain vous pouviez nous faire passer
des exemples précis de dysfonctionnement
sur le fameux guichet numérique
ça nous servirait
s'alimenterait nos questionnements
auprès du directeur de l'INPI lors de
notre visite
voilà
[Musique]
voilà donc merci encore de votre
présence de la richesse de des échanges
merci aux rapporteur qui mesure
l'ampleur de leur tâches et merci chers
collègues de votre présence et aux
administratifs de leur accompagnement et
alors on est jeudi oui on parle le
weekend encore belle continuation